Despite critics' favorable reception of USA
Network's dark teen drama Dare Me, it wasn't
until the show's ten episodes debuted on Netflix
that it truly garnered attention.
Now, the cheerleading thriller, based on Megan
Abbott's novel of the same name, is keeping
everyone on the edge of their seats as it
recently hit the number seven spot in the
most-watched TV series on Netflix in the U.S..
Gritty teen dramas are always in season, and
Dare Me captivates audiences in an effective
way by pulling viewers into the lives of cheerleaders
and best friends Beth Cassidy, played by Marlo
Kelly, and Addy Hanlon, played by Herizen
F. Guardiola.
The story is sent into motion when the new
cheerleading coach Colette French, played
by Willa Fitzgerald, arrives and takes away
Beth's power over the squad.
With its promise of blood and its depiction
of the darker side of cheerleading, Dare Me
more than delivers on the thriller aspect.
Steve Greene from IndieWire wrote that whenever
a member of the cheerleading squad goes, quote,
"flying through the air, a safe landing is
never guaranteed."
He added,
"Watching these aerial maneuvers against a
sea of psychological chaos is the contrast
that not only gives this USA series its anxiety,
but [also] its artistry."
Dare Me's success lies in the performances
of its leads and its carefully built atmosphere.
USA Network Critics generally agreed that
the series' three leads, who hadn't been in
many notable roles before Dare Me, performed
wonderfully.
"I'm the captain.
We're not doing captains anymore.
No, I'm captain.
This is my squad.
Wrong.
It's mine."
The Hollywood Reporter's Daniel Fienberg wrote,
"Kelly, in particular, has a magnetic pull
to her and an effortless ability to transition
from 'innocent to animalistic.
[...] Dare Me features a tantalizing blend
of guilty-pleasure trashiness, smart genre
deconstruction and unfiltered, darkly comic
adrenaline."
Fienberg also compared the show to both Netflix's
You and HBO's Euphoria, but argued Dare Me
was better.
Still, if there is one misstep these cheerleaders
make, it's dragging the story on for a few
episodes too long.
Alan Sepinwall of Rolling Stone wrote in his
review of the show,
"Abbott and her TV collaborators are much
more interested in atmosphere than plot.
The latter takes a very long time to materialize,
though the former becomes so intoxicating
that the long wait begins to feel besides
the point."
In the end, Dare Me isn't here to make anyone
comfortable, but instead to explore something
dark buried within its teenage leads.
In the wake of the show's meteoric rise to
the top ten most popular series on Netflix,
viewers who've been fans of the series since
it first premiered on USA Network in December
2019 are experiencing a wave of hope.
Specifically, fans are hoping that the show's
success on the streaming platform will be
enough for either USA Network itself to reverse
course and renew the series for a second season,
or for Netflix to pick it up and hand down
a season 2 order.
One fan tweeted,
"Can Netflix take Dare Me and make a season
2 [please?]."
Another fan tweeted directly to Netflix, tagging
the company's account and then stating,
"Hey Dare Me is in your top 10 shows and trending,
ya think you wanna pick it up for a season
2 please??"
Even audiences who are just now getting into
Dare Me thanks to its arrival on Netflix are
clamoring for more.
Fans new and old have joined forces to create
and sign a petition urging Netflix to renew
the show for a second season.
This is in addition to the many "save Dare
Me" petitions created at the time the series'
cancellation was announced in April 2020.
While it remains to be seen whether the requests
will have any significance in the eyes of
Netflix executives, it can't hurt to try.
"You are so close to having everything that
you want."
Fingers crossed — and pom-poms up — that
good news will be around the corner for Dare
Me.
If nothing else, though, at least the series
will be remembered as one that captivated
audiences as soon as it aired its first episode
and continued creating buzz over a year later.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.